Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere.
Kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlaff und ich begrüße alle hier zur 71.
Gesprächsrunde rund um viele, viele Themen, die das All betreffen.
Das Ganze wie immer in Zusammenarbeit mit der Stiftung Planetarium Berlin.
Ja und heute wollen wir ein Thema aufgreifen, was ich tatsächlich schon in mehreren
Sendungen auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise schon mal angesprochen habe.
Es gab mal eine Sendung über Weltraumschrott mit Holger Krag.
Wir haben uns ja auch schon mal über das ESA-Programm Space Situational Awareness
mit Detlef Koschny unterhalten. und auch die Asteroiden und Kometen waren schon mal ein Thema.
Und naja, ihr ahnt es schon, die Melange daraus soll heute ein wenig im Fokus stehen.
Nämlich, was ist denn nun hier eigentlich mit den Asteroiden los und sind die
eigentlich eine Gefahr für uns? Und wenn ja, was kann man dagegen tun?
Ja, und dazu begrüße ich erstmal meinen Gesprächspartner, nämlich den Rüdiger. Rüdiger Jehn, hallo.
Hallo.
Wir sind in Darmstadt hier am Europäischen Raumfahrtkontrollzentrum, dem ESOC,
hier war ich ja schon oft und du bist hier beim ESOC genau in dem Programm,
was ich schon erwähnt habe, Space Situational Awareness.
Ich habe mich mit Detlef Koschny 2012 darüber unterhalten, da war das alles
noch so ein bisschen auf dem Weg.
Würde mich natürlich dann auch gleich mal interessieren, wie sich das entwickelt
hat, aber ich würde erst gerne mal ein bisschen mit dir einsteigen,
was so eigentlich dein weg in die raumfahrt geebnet hat wo fing das an,
Mondlandungsbeobachter? Nee, nicht mehr, ne?
Doch, doch, da war ich gerade sechs Jahre. Da durfte man nachts aufstehen.
Das war schon faszinierend.
Ich habe mit neun Jahren Sternkarten gemalt. Ich war von Sternen immer fasziniert.
Und war für mich klar, Astronomie ist ein Traum. Und wenn hier in Darmstadt
das Raumfahrtzentrum ist, ich komme aus Aschaffenburg, war das für mich dann
der Traumjob, da mal zu arbeiten.
Und direkt an der Quelle zu sitzen, wenn es um Beobachtung, um Flüge zu Planeten
geht. Das war immer mein Kindheitstraum.
Überzeugungstäter sozusagen.
Was hast du dann gemacht, um diesen Weg zu ebnen?
Ich habe Mathematik in Darmstadt studiert, habe auch dann Vorlesungen in Raumfahrtmechanik gehört.
Der Professor Fluri damals hat die Vorlesung gehalten. Er hat hier in der Missionsanalyse
gearbeitet, hat gesagt, Wer Interesse hat, kann Diplomarbeit schreiben.
Habe dann meine Masterarbeit zum Thema Mission zum Mars geschrieben.
Und die ESA bietet Stipendien an.
Ich habe mich auf ein Stipendium beworben, habe das dann bekommen,
habe dann als Stipendiat angefangen.
Und in der Zeit, wo ich da gearbeitet habe als Stipendiat, wurde eine Stelle
frei als Datenbankadministrator von dem ganzen Weltraumschrott.
Da habe ich schon 1990 angefangen, die Datenbank aufzubauen,
in der jetzt 20.000 Schrottteile enthalten sind und so habe ich den Einstieg gefunden.
Und dem Thema bist du dann auch gleich treu geblieben sozusagen?
Ja, ich habe mich jahrelang mit Weltraummüll befasst, habe dann aber auch eine
Zeit lang, weil ich mathematischen Hintergrund habe,
die Baby-Colombo-Mission zum Planeten Merkur betreut und habe die Bahn berechnet,
wie fliegt man am kostengünstigsten zum Merkur.
Das sind Optimierungsaufgaben, wo man als Mathematiker da ganz gut aufgehoben
ist und die Voraussetzungen hat, diese Arbeit zu machen.
Zusammen mit Elsa Montagon nehme ich an, welche ihr auch schon darüber gesprochen hatte.
Sie ist mehr auf der Spacecraft-Seite. Also die machen die Operations von dem Baby Colombo.
Aber einer muss auch die Flugbahn berechnen. Und das wird in der Abteilung Missionsanalyse
hier in Darmstadt gemacht. Und da habe ich jahrelang dort gearbeitet.
Das war ja, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, war das ja so eine der größten Herausforderungen
dieser Mission, genau diese Flugbahn zu berechnen für BP Colombo.
Ja, man wundert sich vielleicht, Merkur, der ist ja in der Nähe von der Sonne,
ist ja eigentlich ganz nah.
Aber man muss eben sehr stark abbremsen, zum Mars zu fliegen.
Das dauert sechs Monate, aber zum Merkur, da sind wir jetzt sieben Jahre,
werden wir unterwegs sein.
Der Start ist für Ende des Jahres geplant und man macht da zwei Venus-Vorbeiflüge
und an sich Merkur-Vorbeiflüge, das ist eine sehr komplexe Flugbahn,
die dann noch angereichert wird mit Ionentriebwerken,
also mit Bahnssegmenten, wo man bremst und beschleunigt und das ist ein sehr
komplexes Optimierungsproblem.
Da steigt die Spannung bestimmt jetzt enorm, so zum Ende des Jahres.
Wann ist der Start? Im November?
Oktober, es wird geplant sein und ich bin mal gespannt, falls es gut geht. Herz ist noch dabei.
Ja, okay, toi toi toi. Da sind wir alle ganz gespannt, wie das sich so entwickeln wird.
Genau, ich habe es schon erwähnt, Space Situational Awareness ist dann halt
so ein Programm, was vor einigen Jahren neu aufgesetzt wurde.
Inwiefern war das dann anders als vorher, als das dann aktiv wurde?
Ja, die Direktoren und die Mitgliedstaaten haben eben gemeint,
wir müssen jetzt konkret ein Programm aufsetzen, was jetzt alle Gefahren aus
dem Weltraum behandelt.
Und da ist eben die Asteroiden eine Gefahr, die andere sind Weltraummüll.
Und das dritte ist Space Weather, das ist die Sonne, wenn die Eruption hat und
riesige Ionen auswirft, Protonen, die auf die Erde einströmen und da unsere
Atmosphäre beeinflussen.
Das hat man unter einem Schirm gespannt. und die Asteroidenabwehr ist ein Drittel davon,
eine von den drei Pfeilern und da haben wir jetzt eine Abteilung,
die seit Beginn schon einiges gewachsen ist. Sie haben gesagt,
2012 haben wir das letzte Mal gesprochen.
Inzwischen haben wir in Italien ein Koordinationszentrum eingerichtet.
Das sind vier hauptberufliche Mitarbeiter, die da arbeiten, die hauptsächlich
unsere Webseiten täglich aktualisieren, um die Öffentlichkeit zu informieren,
wie die Gefahr von Asteroiden beschaffen ist,
was sind die Objekte, die wir jetzt im Blick haben,
wann können die die Erde treffen, was ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, wie groß sind die.
Und ja, da haben wir vier Leute, die sich rund um die Uhr damit beschäftigen.
Da ist ein Beobachter, der unser Teleskop benutzt, um eben den Himmel abzusuchen,
ob da irgendwo versteckte neue Asteroiden auftauchen.
Das heißt, es gibt jetzt hier, das ist quasi so eine Dienstleistungsgruppe innerhalb
des gesamten ESOG-Körpers.
Wie steht man da mit anderen Projekten in Verbindung?
Ja, das ist weniger wie bei Space Debris,
da sind ja ständig unsere Satelliten bedroht vom Weltraumschrott und die müssen
dann quasi den anderen Satellitenbetreibern oder unseren Satelliten täglich
oder wöchentlich Bericht erstatten.
Hier ist ein Trümmerteil, der ausweichen müsste.
Unsere Kundschaft ist eigentlich mehr die Öffentlichkeit, weil wir haben keine
täglichen oder wöchentlichen Warnungen.
Jetzt kommt ein Asteroid, ihr müsst eure Satelliten parken, umlenken oder auf Sicherheit stellen.
Das ist eigentlich nicht unser Gebiet. Das ist einfach viel zu selten.
Und die kleinen Teile, die kleinen Asteroiden, sagen wir mal kleiner als ein
Meter, die eigentlich regelmäßig die Erde treffen, die sehen wir einfach nicht rechtzeitig.
Das sind Sternschnuppen oder größere Feuerbälle nachts, die treffen uns immer
noch überraschend, was aber auch okay ist, weil die stellen ja keine große Gefahr
dar. Die verglühen, bevor sie auf der Erde herunterkommen.
Und davor können wir einfach keine Warnung rechtzeitig ausstellen.
Beziehungsweise man muss auch nicht unbedingt warnen, weil sie sind zu klein.
Stellen keine wirkliche Gefahr da, meine ich.
Gut, wir hatten jetzt letztes Jahr, hier über Darmstadt hat er angefangen zu
glühen. Und er ist bis nach Trier rüber geflogen.
Er hat so ein Schleif von 200, 300 Kilometern. Richtig großer Feuerball.
Die Leute in Aufregung versetzt. Der war vielleicht so fußballgroß und ist da verglüht.
Und da waren 2000 Leute, die das gemeldet haben. Da waren auf dem Internet Bilder, die man gesehen hat.
Die Leute haben das gefilmt. Und die Leute fragen, was ist das?
Und ich war dann auch in der Hessenschau eingeladen, um aufzuklären,
dass es halt nur ein ganz normaler, etwas größerer Asteroid ist,
der in die Atmosphäre eingetreten ist und verglüht und keinerlei Gefahr darstellt.
Aber die Leute sind erstmal verängstigt und sieht man selten in seinem Leben.
Also wenn man es einmal gesehen hat, dann kann man eigentlich froh sein,
dass man das mal erlebt hat, weil es selten ist.
Was ist so das Rüstzeug oder anders gefragt Weltraumschrott da denkt man ja
eigentlich die ganze Zeit naja das ist ja eh bekannt das fliegt da irgendwie rum,
was kann man das nicht alles so weit vorberechnen dass man über Wochen und Monate
und Jahre hinaus vorher schon weiß wo die langfliegen und kann das von vornherein
alles einplanen warum muss immer kurz vorher Bescheid gesagt werden wenn man
das irgendwie eh schon weiß.
Der große Unterschied ist den Weltraumschrott. Der kreist um die Erde herum,
den kann man regelmäßig sehen.
Da stellt man irgendwo ein Radar hin und irgendwann in 24 Stunden fliegt das
durch den Kegel vom Radar.
Und die Amerikaner haben da ein weltweites Überwachungssystem,
die haben ihre 20.000 Teile im Katalog drin und es wird einmal die Woche upgedatet,
dann sieht man das Teil wieder.
Ach, das hat sich ein bisschen anders bewegt, wie wir eigentlich vorhergesagt
haben, weil der Luftwiderstand doch etwas anders war.
Und das ist eine normale Arbeit, die man mit.
Teleskopen… Also diese Vorhersagbarkeit ist so gar nicht gegeben,
weil einfach da zu viele Unwägbarkeiten noch drin sind.
Das ist bei Space Depree relativ gut. Nur bei Asteroiden, es gibt 150.000 Objekte
größer als 100 Meter. Das ist unsere Schätzung.
Wir wissen nicht genau, wie viel da draußen herumkreist.
Und wir können die nur sehen, wenn die ganz nah an die Erde herankommen.
Wenn die draußen beim Mars bis zur Venus hereinkommen und sind weit weg,
die sind nur zehn Meter groß, dann haben wir keine Chance, mit den größten Teleskopen
die zu sehen. Wir sehen erst, wenn die in die Nähe kommen.
Und es gibt tausende von diesen Teilen, die kommen uns einmal nahe und dann
sind sie wieder 100 Jahre verschwunden, bis die Erde das nächste Mal wieder nahe kommt.
Und von diesen 100.000, größer als 100 Meter, haben wir bisher erst 5% beobachtet
und 95%, die kommen jetzt in den nächsten Jahren irgendwann mal an die Erde in der Nähe vorbei.
Und dann entdecken wir die ein paar Wochen vorher, bevor sie der Erde richtig nahe kommen.
Und das Ziel ist eben, mehr Teleskope einzusetzen, größere Teleskope einzusetzen,
dass wir statt 5% eben vielleicht 80% von den Teilen schon kennen.
Und dann können wir das wie mit dem Space Zubrie auch machen,
besser Vorhersagen und genauere Vorhersagen zu machen.
Welche Teleskope kommen da zum Einsatz?
Wir benutzen ein Ein-Meter-Teleskop, das steht in Teneriffa.
Das teilen wir uns auch mit den Leuten, die Weltraummüll suchen.
Das haben wir vier Tage pro Monat zur Verfügung und da scannen wir den Himmel ab.
Aber das ist viel zu wenig, um den ganzen Himmel abzuscannen.
Wir bauen jetzt an einem FlyEye-Teleskop, Fliegenauge-Teleskop.
Das ist auch ein Meter groß, aber der große Unterschied ist,
es kann ein riesengroßes Gesichtsfeld am Himmel abdecken.
Wir können mit diesem Teleskop innerhalb von 48 Stunden die ganze nördliche
Halbkugel abscannen und Objekte und Asteroiden finden, die kurz vorm Einschlag wären.
Das soll 2019 in Sizilien aufgestellt werden und dann wären wir in der Lage,
viel besser vorherzusagen, was auf uns zukommt. Aber bisher sind wir noch ganz
auf die Amerikaner angewiesen.
Die haben in Hawaii das Panstar-System, die haben ein Catalina-System,
aber die scannen den Himmel nicht komplett ab.
Da sind noch große Lücken, die sie nur alle drei, vier Wochen komplett abscannen
können. Also da ist immer noch viele Sachen, die ständig überraschend kommen,
die man eigentlich schon Wochen vorher sehen hätte können, wenn man da hingeschaut
hätte. Aber hätte, hätte.
Es gibt nicht genügend Teleskope. Und das ist eben die große Aufgabe,
an der wir jetzt arbeiten, diese Lücken zu schließen.
Also auch neue Teleskope nachzuliefern, weitere aufzubauen.
Das erste, wie gesagt, soll jetzt in Sizilien schon nächstes Jahr aufgebaut werden.
Ein zweites planen wir dann in der südlichen Halbkugel, dass wir eben auch die
Einschläge, die aus dem Süden kommen, abfangen können, dass wir dann in der
nächsten Periode von unserem SSA-Programm kommen.
Idealerweise wären vier Teleskope, weil, wie gesagt, wir brauchen 48 Stunden,
um den ganzen Himmel abzuscannen.
Wenn wir zwei in der nördlichen Halbkugel und zwei in der südlichen hätten,
können wir das jede Nacht komplett in den Himmel abscannen.
Und dann wären wir eigentlich ganz gut gewappnet gegen unvorhergesehene Ankömmlinge.
Woran scheitert das, so eine Infrastruktur aufzubauen?
Ja, das kostet erst mal Geld, das Ganze.
Da müsste einfach viel mehr Geld investiert werden.
Also an Standorten würde es jetzt nicht mangeln?
Nee, Standorte eigentlich weniger. Du könntest sie auch direkt nebeneinander
stellen. Das eine scannt die Hälfte vom Himmel ab, die andere Hälfte.
Also das ist nicht das Problem. Das Problem ist wirklich, dass uns das Geld
fehlt, um das schneller umzusetzen.
Warum heißt das Ding FlyEye? Also ist das irgendwie wie ein Fliegenauge gebaut
oder nur weil es Sachen beobachtet, die fliegen?
Nee, das hat wirklich was mit der Stubenfliege zu tun.
Dieses Teleskop ist ganz speziell. Es hat 16 Kameras. Das heißt,
das Licht wird eingesammelt und wird dann aufgeteilt auf 16 verschiedene Kameras.
Das ist wie die Facettenaugen von einer Fliege.
Man teilt das Gesichtsfeld in 16 Quadraten auf und jede Kamera hat einen Teil
von dem Gesichtsfeld abgedeckt.
Und es wird dann wieder zusammengesetzt mit dem Computer.
Und eben genau wie die Stubenfliege hat man da eben ein sehr großes Gesichtsfeld,
weil jede einzelne Kamera deckt 1,7 Grad ab und dann hat man halt 16-fache von
diesem Feld, kriegt man mit diesem Teleskop.
Wer entwickelt das?
Das wird in Italien gebaut. Die Firma wurde aufgekauft von OHB.
OHB gibt es in Bremen und die haben Carlo Gavazza Space in Italien aufgekauft
und das ist eine Kooperation und das wird von den alten Mitarbeitern von Carlo
Gavazza Space in Italien in Mailand gebaut.
Aber es ist direkt von der ESA beauftragt.
Wir sind der Auftraggeber, wir haben den spezifiziert, wir haben genau geschrieben,
das Teleskop muss das und das können und die setzen es dann um,
was wir gefordert haben.
Aber im Prinzip könnten die anderen drei wünschenswerten Standorte dann eigentlich
mit genau derselben Technologie bestückt werden.
Das ist geplant.
Also man muss jetzt zumindest nichts Neues erfinden, man muss halt sozusagen
nur mehr davon produzieren und mehr betreiben.
Ja, und für das Zweite haben wir auch konkret schon ein Budget vorgesehen.
Wir wissen, was das kosten soll.
Und wir haben auch schon mit ESO, die European Southern Observatory,
verhandelt, wo wir das aufstellen dürfen. Da sind wir schon weit vorangeschritten.
Also die ersten beiden, die sind in Bearbeitung.
Das heißt Südhalbkubel würde dann auch in der Atacama-Wüste unterkommen?
Das ist bei La Silla, das ist ein bisschen weiter südlich. Wenn man von Santiago
de Chile an die Küste rausfliegt,
Valparaiso und dann noch ein bisschen nördlich in den Anden auf 3000 Meter Höhe,
4000 Meter Höhe, da stehen schon viele Teleskope.
Da steht auch dieses Very Large Telescope, das 8 Meter Durchmesser hat und da
soll es eigentlich nebendran gestellt werden.
Weil da ist halt gute Sicht.
Da ist gute Sicht, jede Nacht ist da klar und das ideale Beobachtungsverhältnis dort.
Das heißt, es ist zumindest absehbar, dass man irgendwann auch so auf so eine
Realtime-die-ganze-Welt-Coverage kommt, auch wenn man noch nicht so ganz da ist.
Ja,
also man sollte dann schon größere Objekte, so 20 Meter große,
die würde man vielleicht zwei, drei Wochen vorher sehen.
Es kommt darauf an, wie schnell die sind und es kommt auch darauf an, wie hell die sind.
Es gibt ja, nennt man Albedo, wie groß die Rückstrahlung ist,
wenn die sehr schwarz sind, das sieht man später.
Wenn die sehr stark Sonnenlicht reflektieren, dann wird man sie früher sehen.
Aber die Idee ist, dass man so 20 Meter große Teile so zwei,
drei Wochen vorher entdecken kann und dann die eine Woche lang beobachtet und
berechnet, wo könnten die einschlagen.
Und dann könnte man eine Warnung herausgeben. Also in diesem Gebiet ist mit
einem Einschlag zu rechnen.
Genau, kommen wir doch mal so ein bisschen auf die Asteroiden selber.
Ich hatte ja schon mal eine längere Sendung zum Wesen der Asteroiden.
Kurz gesagt, das ist sozusagen alles, was nicht Kometen und Planeten sind.
Sozusagen das, was so übrig geblieben ist. Und zwischen Mars und Jupiter haben
wir diesen monströsen Asteroidengürtel mit was weiß ich wie vielen Objekten.
Gibt es da eigentlich überhaupt eine Schätzung, was da rumfliegt?
Also die Zahl, die ich jetzt im Kopf habe, wir haben 650.000 schon beobachtet.
Aber das ist unerschöpflich. Also je besser die Teleskope werden,
desto mehr wird man sehen. Es kommt auf die Grenzgröße, die man setzt.
Also wenn man da runter geht bis zu einem Meter, dann sind es Millionen, die da herumkreisen.
Aber die sind zu klein, die können wir momentan noch nicht sehen.
Ja, das ist jetzt auch nicht so, wie man das aus Transfiction-Feldern-Filmen
kennt, dass man da so links-rechts steuern muss, um da irgendwie durchzufliegen.
Die haben enorme Abstände übereinander.
Ja, der Weltraum ist ja auch riesig groß und selbst wenn da Millionen sind,
kommt man da noch relativ gut durch.
Die Voyager-Sonden, Galileo und so, die sind ja alle.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz ist dieser Asteroidengürtel halt unter Dauerfeuer durch den Jupiter,
der das mit seiner Gravitation immer wieder ordentlich durcheinander wirft und
deswegen ist da keine Stabilität in diesem System und es wird immer mal wieder
was rausgekickt und es gibt immer mal wieder so kleine Kugeln,
die so auf Reise geschickt werden dadurch.
Ja gut, die in dem Asteroidengürtel, die sind meistens schon in Resonanzen angehalten vom Jupiter.
Was durcheinander bringt, sind Kometen, die aus der ortslichen Wolke kommen.
Aber eigentlich, was die Bahn stark verändert ist, wenn die Asteroiden Vorbeiflüge
haben am Mars, in der Nähe vom Jupiter, wenn sie in der Nähe vom Jupiter kommen,
wird die Bahn stark gestört.
Das kann man aber alles sehr gut vorher berechnen. Wenn man ein Asteroid mal
beobachtet hat und gut die Bahn vermessen hat, dann kann man den über Jahre berechnen.
Also wir haben in unserer Datenbank Objekte, da wissen wir, dass im Jahr 2800
vielleicht die Erde treffen könnten.
Also wir berechnen es wirklich über 1000 Jahre voraus und können es verblüffend genau vorhersagen.
Also Objekte, die jetzt sozusagen schon auf einem abweichenden Pfad sind oder
vor allem, indem man jetzt schon weiß, dass sie dann irgendwann mal vom Jupiter rausgekickt werden?
Ja, die werden nicht rausgekickt, sondern die sind schon auf einer Bahn,
wo wir wissen, dass sie im Jahr 2800 der Erde nahe kommen.
Und die werden gestört durch Mars und Jupiter, auch durch die Erde sehr stark,
weil sie jetzt schon in der Nähe von der Erde vorbeikommen.
Und die werden da hin und her geschleudert ein bisschen, aber hergeschleudert
ist ein bisschen übertrieben, weil die Bahnen ändern sich nur geringfügig.
Aber es reicht halt, dass es irgendwann die Erdbahn genau kreuzt.
Das heißt, man hat jetzt so eine halbwegs gute Vorstellung davon,
dass da einerseits eine ganze Menge Asteroiden sind, die wenigsten davon werden
jemals für uns in irgendeiner Form ein Problem sein, aber manche unter Umständen eben schon.
Und es ist ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass wir keine Begegnungen haben.
Wir hatten ja eben schon das Beispiel mit den ganz Kleinen.
Also die Sternschnuppe ist halt einfach letzten Endes auch nichts anderes als
ein Asteroid, bloß halt so klein, dass man das Problem eigentlich und da sieht
schön aus abspeichern kann und dann war es das mit der Bedrohung.
Aber es gab ja jetzt gerade, das hatte ich ja gesagt, wir hatten uns schon mal
hier 2012 mit dem Thema ein weiteres Mal auseinandergesetzt,
ist ja seitdem auch einiges passiert.
Was sind denn so nennenswerte Ereignisse gewesen, die uns dieses Problem immer
wieder neu unter die Nase gehalten haben?
Also die beste PR für uns, für manche Leute war das kein Spaß,
war in Tscheljabinsk in Russland, ist am 15.
Februar 2013, also gerade fünf Jahre her, ist ein 20 Meter großer Asteroid tagsüber
am Taghimmel über der Stadt explodiert.
Der hat einen riesen Feuerschweif, da haben die Leute gefilmt am Himmel,
ist der entlanggezogen, ist dann etwa 30 Kilometer über dem Boden explodiert
und hat eine riesen Schockwelle erzeugt.
Die Schockwelle hat die Stadt getroffen, da sind die Fenster zersplittert.
Wenn jemand in der Nähe vom Fenster stand, hat Scherben ins Gesicht bekommen,
Da waren 1500 Leute im Krankenhaus, haben sich behandeln lassen.
Es gab keine Toten, aber es gab viele Verletzte.
Ich habe Videos gesehen, da sind Türen umgefallen auf Leute drauf.
Da ist eine riesige Druckwelle, die hat eine Wellblechstecher weggebrochen. Das ist wie ein Tornado.
Der zieht da durch die Stadt und hinterlässt seine Trümmerspur.
Und das zeigt uns eben, dass es nicht graue Theorie ist und dass es nicht alle
100 Millionen Jahre mal vorkommt, sondern wirklich solche Teile,
die treffen uns immer wieder.
Wir haben abgeschätzt, statistisch kommt es zwar nur alle 50 Jahre vor,
aber das ist jetzt vorgekommen, war über eine Stadt.
Und in dem Fall hat es ernsthafte Konsequenzen gehabt.
Und beim nächsten Mal wollen wir eben dafür vorbereitet sein.
Die Idee ist eben, wenn man das eine Woche vorher ankündigen kann,
dann kann man zumindest den Leuten sagen, genau wie bei einer Tornadowarnung,
um die Uhrzeit erwarten wir eine Druckwelle.
Bleibt bitte in geschlossenen Räumen, macht die Fensterläden runter,
geht nicht auf die Straße und da ist mit einer Druckwelle zu rechnen.
Und da könnte man viele Schäden vermeiden, wenn man einfach weiß, dass sowas kommt.
20 Meter Durchmesser in Schelljabins, aber es gab hier keinerlei Vorwarnung.
Nein, das wussten wir nicht. Wobei man auch dazu sagen muss,
auch diese Objekte werden wir mit unserem FlyEye-Teleskop nicht sehen,
weil der von der Sonne kam.
Und mit Teleskopen kann man eben nur die Nachtseite abscannen.
Und wenn da eine wochenlang von der Sonnenseite herkommt und dann die Erde trifft,
dann würden wir den auch nicht sehen.
Wir müssen den schon vorher sehen, wenn er sich noch am Nachthimmel aufhält,
wir müssen die da schon viele Monate vorher beobachten, was für Größere möglich ist.
Und das ist auch das Ziel, dass wir die schon teilweise Jahre vorher beobachten,
und dann Vorhersagen machen können, wann es die Erde trifft.
Aber es bleibt ein Restrisiko von Objekten wie etwa 10, 20 Meter,
die einfach zu klein sind, dass wir sie Monate vorher sehen können und die dann
doch wieder die Erde treffen können von der Sonnenseite her und da hätten wir
keine Abwärmmaßnahmen.
Wobei ich halt sagen will, mit diesen Teleskopen können wir einen großen Teil
schon abdecken und entdecken, aber nicht 100 Prozent.
Also die Sicherheit wird nicht zu 100 Prozent gewährleistet sein.
Der schöne Satz. Aber 20 Meter wäre jetzt problemlos sehbar,
entdeckbar gewesen, wäre jetzt nicht von der Sonne ausgekommen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall, ja. Den würde man drei Wochen vorher sehen.
Wenn er jetzt von der anderen Seite gekommen wäre, kann man den drei Wochen vorher sehen.
Hat genügend Zeit, die Bahn sehr präzise zu bestimmen, genau zu berechnen, wo er einschlagen wird.
Und dann hätten wir sagen können, in diesem Gebiet von vielleicht einer Strecke
von 500 Kilometern wird er abstürzen.
Einen Tag vorher wird man es vielleicht noch besser berechnen können,
dass man ein kleines Gebiet, vielleicht die Stadt sagt, ja hier,
wir wissen, es wird auf Chelyabinsk zukommen.
Und wird dann die Sicherheitsbehörden informieren, wird sagen,
da kommt was, bereitet eure Bevölkerung drauf vor.
Und dann ist es, wie gesagt, wie eine Tornadowarnung. Und wenn man sich drauf
vorbereitet, dann kann vieles vermieden werden.
Wie viel ist so von dem übrig geblieben, wenn er mit 20 Metern auf die Erde eintrifft?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie viele Kilogramm, aber die haben einige Teile gefunden.
Da ist dann auch in See seiner Nähe, da sind viele Sachen rein,
da ist es schwierig, das zu finden. Aber die haben einige.
Also er platzt auf. Der explodiert. Er explodiert einfach durch die Hitze.
Durch die Hitze, er hat so viel Energie, muss der aufnehmen,
dass er irgendwann explodiert. Und dann diese riesen Druckwelle erzeugt.
20 Meter, das ist schon ordentlich Brocken.
Den würde man jetzt auch so nicht unbedingt auf sich drauf sehen wollen.
Aber durch die enorme geschwindigkeit multipliziert sich das ja oder ist das ja quasi.
Der schiebt die atmosphäre vor sich hin und heizt sich dadurch auf und das ist
wie beim überflug über schallflugzeug irgendwann tut es einen knall und dann
steht entsteht diese schockwelle.
Gute Werbung sei das gewesen, in Anführungsstrichen.
Ja, wie gesagt, wir sind ja sicher weit weg.
Aber unser Programm hilft das natürlich sehr viel, weil die Politiker,
die entscheiden, wo das Geld hingeht, die sehen, oh ja, das ist wirklich ein
tägliches Risiko, dass die Bevölkerung ausgesetzt ist.
Und als Politiker haben wir die Verantwortung, für die Sicherheit der Leute zu sorgen.
Und da muss man das Thema auch ernst nehmen. Da kann ich sagen,
das kommt vielleicht mal in tausend Jahren und Politiker denken nur vier Jahre
Legislaturperiode weit, schieben das vor sich hin.
Also das hat uns geholfen, Unterstützung zu bekommen.
Und das hat dann auch stattgefunden oder ist das nur so theoretisch?
Naja, also unser Budget, das wurde jetzt, wir haben das in drei Phasen,
wir sind jetzt in der dritten Phase, das wurde im Vergleich zur zweiten Phase verdoppelt.
Wir haben jetzt doppelt so viel Geld zur Verfügung wie in der zweiten Phase
und können das FlyEye-Teleskop ausbauen und also finanziell sind wir in dieser
Richtung ganz gut aufgestellt.
Würde man sich ja noch mehr Meteore wünschen, die einschlagen,
wenn es ein bisschen dunkel ist, solche Forderungen zu stellen.
Ja, irgendwo, wo es keinem weh tut.
Ja, aber es gab ja noch ein paar andere interessante Asteroidensichtungen,
gerade vor ein paar Monaten gab es ja nochmal so ein besonderes Objekt,
auch mit einer besonderen Form, was weiß man darüber?
Ja, der Interstellare, das war natürlich das absolute Highlight im letzten Jahr 2017.
Der Oua-Mua-Mua wurde ja genannt, weil er mit Teleskopen in Hawaii entdeckt
wurde. Und Oumuamua ist hawaiianisch, der Späher aus weit her irgendwie, so etwas.
Und das ist halt zum ersten Mal, dass ein interstellares Objekt beobachtet wurde.
Der kommt irgendwo außerhalb von unserem Sonnensystem, ist seit hunderttausend
von Jahren, treibt er durch die Galaxie.
Woher weiß man das?
Man hat versucht auszurechnen, wo der herkommt. und hat zurückgerechnet und
hat, was ich gelesen habe, 100.000 Jahre ist er an keinem Stern vorbeigekommen.
Er muss ja von irgendwo her kommen.
Normalerweise wird man vermuten, der Jupiter schmeißt auch kleine Asteroiden
aus unserem Sonnensystem heraus. Die fliegen dann in unsere Galaxie weiter herum.
Und genauso muss der ja auch irgendwo aus dem Sonnensystem herausgeschleudert
worden sein und ist irgendwann zu uns gekommen.
Aber wir haben die Sonne nicht gefunden, von der er herkommt.
Also er muss vielleicht Millionen Jahre irgendwo da rumgegeistert sein und ist
jetzt an der Sonne, ist zu uns gekommen,
fliegt da kurz vorbei und ist jetzt schon wieder, glaube ich,
am Jupiter schon wieder vorbei.
Den kann man nur noch mit den ganz großen Teleskopen sehen.
Die Amerikaner haben mit ihren...
Jetzt schon wieder beim Jupiter, da muss er ja extrem schnell unterrichtet werden.
Der ist sehr, sehr schnell. Der hat eine riesen Geschwindigkeit,
also hyperbolische Geschwindigkeit.
Der hat ja Fluchtgeschwindigkeit auf dem Sonnensystem. Der ist kein...
Der hat genügend Geschwindigkeit, um hereinzukommen, wieder herauszukommen.
Und die Amerikaner haben wirklich, ich finde es immer faszinierend,
was die Amerikaner alles treiben,
die haben da ihre Radioteleskope auf diesen Asteroiden gerichtet und haben abgehört,
ob da Handybetrieb oder ob da irgendwelche Funksignale gesendet werden,
ob da vielleicht doch Leben oder so drauf sind.
Der Monolith, da ist er.
Ja, der Alessi Clark hat diesen Roman Rondeville Drama geschrieben,
wo auch ähnlich aus Interstellar so ein Teil ankommt.
Das war aber dann, also ein Raumschiff und war kein Asteroid.
Und das Faszinierende an diesem Asteroid jetzt ist diese Form.
Der hat ja ein Verhältnis von der Längsachse zur Querachse, von 1 zu 10 wird
geschätzt, was im ganzen Sonnensystem unbekannt ist.
Da ist richtig so ein langgestrecktes, wie so eine Zigarette,
so ein Zigarillo wurde auch gemalt.
Wir haben ja nur Radarbilder, wir haben keine richtig optischen Bilder,
aber im Internet, wenn man nach ihm sucht, findet man tolle Computeranimationen
Und das sieht dann aus wie ein riesen Zigarillo und so einen Teil kannten wir vorher nicht.
Das ist verblüffend, warum hat er diese Form und die Spekulanten haben dann
natürlich gleich gemeint, ja das ist ein Raumschiff, das ist aerodynamisch und
das ist so wie bei Rama, so ein Zylinder.
Und es kommt natürlich an der Sonne vorbei, um sich da Schwung zu holen,
um die interstellare Reise zu beschleunigen.
Also das sind tolle Theorien und die Amerikaner haben wirklich ein großes Radioteleskop
benutzt und haben da hingehört, ob da wirklich Signale kommen. Kam natürlich nichts.
Also es ist wohl sehr wahrscheinlich ein ganz normaler Asteroid,
der zufällig da vorbeikam und weil wir jetzt eben anders als noch vor 20 Jahren
viele Teleskope im Einsatz haben, wurde der dann halt entdeckt,
weil diese Objekte, die werden mit Sicherheit häufiger durchs Sonnensystem,
durchgeistern und ja, das war halt jetzt zum ersten Mal, dass wir ihn gesehen
haben und wir finden es immer noch sehr, sehr spannend und Sensationsmeldung.
Wenn man sich jetzt vorstellt, das Objekt hätte jetzt direkt einen Kurs auf die Erde genommen?
Ja gut, da muss man es vorher entdecken, was das Teil ist auch 300 Meter groß,
Das hat man schon ein paar Monate vorher.
Also wenn man sich jetzt mal so den Impact mal vorstellt, was hätte es bedeutet,
wenn dieses Objekt tatsächlich direkt auf die Erde zugerast wäre und irgendwo
aufgetroffen wäre auf die Erde?
300 Meter, das ist schon sehr desaströs.
Also wenn es in Europa einschlägt, da wäre Deutschland ein Riesengrad,
Ja, der würde es erzeugen.
Da wird schon einiges in die Luft, in die Atmosphäre aufgewirbelt.
Es wäre nicht so groß wie bei den Dinosauriern. Da schätzt man ja,
das war ja fast zehn Kilometer groß, der damals vor 65 Millionen Jahren dafür
gesorgt hat, die ganze Klimakatastrophe, die dann zum Aussterben von den Dinosauriern geführt hat.
Also 300 Meter, das ist schon ein großer regionaler Schaden.
Wenn es ins Meer fällt, kommt ein Tsunami.
Also das sind schon mit tausend von Toten zurechnen, je nachdem wo er aufschlägt.
Aber 300 Meter ist schon ein verdammt großer Brocken.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit wäre ja höher, dass er den Ozean trifft.
Macht das einen großen Unterschied?
Ja, das kommt halt darauf an, wo er einschlägt im Ozean und wo dann der Tsunami ankommt.
Zumindest könnte man das dann Tsunami-Warnungen rechtzeitig geben.
Aber es wäre schon eine große Katastrophe. Also mir wäre es lieber,
wenn er da in der Sahara irgendwo einschlägt oder in der Antarktika.
Da wäre er noch am besten aufgehoben. Man kann es sich ja nicht aussuchen.
Okay, aber das wäre auf jeden Fall schlimm.
300 Meter ist schon verdammt groß.
Und der war aber jetzt sehr weit weg von uns.
Und das ist, ich meine, das Interstellar, dass wir da getroffen werden,
das ist sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Aber es gibt, vorhin habe ich gesagt, es gibt noch 95 Prozent,
also fast 150.000 Asteroiden in der Größe von 100 Metern, die wir noch nicht beobachtet haben.
Aber 2017 gab es ja auch einen nicht interstellaren Asteroiden,
der auch relativ nah an uns vorbeigegangen ist. Was war das, 40.000 Kilometer?
Das waren ein Zehntel von der Entfernung vom Mond und das ist selten, das kommt selten vor.
Also das war einer der drei hellsten in den letzten zehn Jahren,
der an der Erde vorbeigeflogen ist.
Das war 2012 TC4 heißt der, der wurde 2012 entdeckt.
Und seitdem haben wir den in unserem Blickfeld, aber 2012 konnte der nur vier
Tage lang beobachtet werden, dann war er zu lichtschwach und das heißt,
man kannte die Bahn nicht so genau,
man wusste nur, er wird wohl an der Erde vorbeikommen, man wusste schon,
dass er die Erde nicht treffen wird, aber er war noch sehr ungenau und die Nase
hat es dann als Beispiel mal herangezogen,
als Übung, wenn so ein Teil jetzt ankommt.
Man wusste ja, so im Juli wird er langsam wieder sichtbar werden.
Im Oktober kommt er ganz nah an der Erde vorbei.
Und wie würden wir jetzt reagieren, wenn wir das im Juli entdecken und wissen,
dass er im Oktober eintrifft?
Wir testen da die internationale Kollaboration, also wir haben mit der ESA gesprochen,
dass wir unser Teleskop benutzen, um den wieder zu entdecken.
Und das wurde dann als Planspiel durchgespielt und wurde auch von den Medien interessant verfolgt.
Also der kam zweimal vorbei?
2012 wurde er zum ersten Mal entdeckt und dann 2017, jetzt im Oktober 2017.
Ach so, er hat in fünf Jahren quasi nochmal so einmal seine Runde fertiggestellt.
Ja, dann kam er zum zweiten Mal dann vorbei. Und da beim zweiten Mal ist er
eben in 40.000 Kilometern an der Erde vorbeigeflogen.
Und dann kommt er in fünf Jahren wieder?
Der kommt irgendwann wieder, aber der wird die in den nächsten 100 Jahren nicht treffen.
Das ist aber sehr unregelmäßig, wann die wieder zurückkommen.
Natürlich ist da irgendein Muster drin, aber das ist nicht so einfach,
dass er alle fünf Jahre kommt, sondern alle fünf Jahre wird es größer und es
ist eine komplizierte Kurve.
Aber er wird uns auch erst mal wieder nicht so nah sein.
Ja, ja.
Weil sonst wäre es ja eine schöne Mission, wo man mal, so nah könnte man ja
problemlos beobachten.
Ja, beobachten. Also das ist ein gutes Objekt um die Teleskope.
Wir wollen jetzt auch mal mit Radar anfangen in Europa zu schauen,
ob wir das sehen können. Das sind wunderbare Testobjekte.
Ich kann mal ein bisschen Werbung für unsere Webseite machen.
Da kann man nämlich sehen, was in den nächsten Jahren oder was jetzt in den
nächsten Monaten bei uns vorbeikommt.
Das ist neo-earth-objects.ssa.esa.int.
Da gibt es zwei interessante Unterseiten. Das eine ist Risklist.
Das sind die Objekte, das sind 700 Objekte, von denen wir nicht ausschließen
können, dass sie die Erde nicht treffen.
Also die haben eine Wahrscheinlichkeit größer als 0, dass sie in den nächsten
100 Jahren die Erde treffen werden.
Und da kennen wir eben 700 Objekte.
Und ja, ich glaube der höchste Palermo-Scale, so wie Erdbeben-Richterskala haben
wir eine Palermo-Scale, die gefährlichsten sind und der soll 2026,
hat er eine Wahrscheinlichkeit von 1 zu 700, dass er die Erde da trifft.
Der ist so 30 Meter, glaube ich, groß und den haben wir da im Blick und normalerweise,
wenn wir das besser berechnen, wird die Wahrscheinlichkeit irgendwann mal zu
Null werden, wenn wir bessere Beobachtungsdaten haben.
Die verschwinden irgendwann wieder aus der Risikoliste. Manche bleiben da auch,
die sind schon fünf Jahre da drin.
Im Jahr 2090 haben die eine Möglichkeit zu treffen.
Und das kann irgendwann, ja, also dafür folgen wir das. Da kann sich auch jeder
informieren, was da gerade aktuell ist.
Auf der anderen Seite ist Close Encounter.
Also ich gucke hier gerade mal rein, da sind ja ganz schöne Brocken dabei. Irgendwie so 860 Meter.
Da ist aber die wahrscheinlichkeit 1 zu 600.000.
Und das auch erst im jahr 2113 das noch ein bisschen zeit ist noch ein bisschen
zeit ja okay was haben wir hier noch irgendwie 2019 gibt es einen 37 meter der ist bei 1 zu 1100,
Ist auch noch nicht so viel, ne? Wo muss man sich denn Sorgen machen?
Ja gut, die sind sortiert nach dieser Palermo-Skala. Palermo-Skala mixt zusammen
die Größe, die Wahrscheinlichkeit und wie lange es noch dauert, bis er uns trifft.
Und das wird da in der Formel gemischt und dann der oberste,
das ist der gefährlichste quasi.
Also ich habe hier zwei Spalten. Das eine ist PS, das ist dann diese Palermo-Skala.
Palermo-Skala und danach wird es dann die IP. IP ist Impact Probability,
die Einschlagswahrscheinlichkeit. die 1 zu 1000 oder was da eben ist.
Hier habe ich auch einmal 1 zu 16.
Ja, aber der ist nur 9 Meter groß, glaube ich.
Und er ist 2095. Die Pappenheimer hier sozusagen.
Aber mal ganz interessant. 1 zu 86 haben wir hier noch.
Der oberste, der ist jetzt seit 100 Tagen oder so. Es steht auch seit wann er
in der letzten Spalte, glaube ich, seit wann er da drin ist.
Der kam da neu. Wir haben quasi unsere Top 10, wie die Hitparade ihre Top Ten
hat, haben wir unsere Top Ten.
Aber unsere ist sehr viel langsamer und die Leute werden nicht rausgeschmissen,
wenn sie jetzt dreimal dabei waren, sondern die sind da jahrelang drin.
Kleiner PR-Tipp. Vielleicht sollte man den Dingern auch mal ein paar putzige
Namen geben, weil die Bedrohung von 2017 RH16 weiß ich nicht,
kommt irgendwie nicht so richtig rüber.
Ja, aber Star Trek, die Roboter, die hießen doch auch so.
Ja gut, aber damit musste man ja auch nicht vor Politikern argumentieren.
Aber wenn man hier vielleicht Einer hat ja sogar einen Namen, Apophis.
Apophis, der war ja lange in der Diskussion, weil der ist 1996,
glaube ich, entdeckt worden oder 2002.
Auf jeden Fall war das in der Bild-Zeitung, die Erde wird 2029 zerstört von dem Apophis.
Der ist über 300 Meter groß und damals hat er eine relativ große Wahrscheinlichkeit
gehabt, die Erde zu treffen.
Inzwischen konnte man das ausschließen, aber dann hat man Angst gehabt,
dass er 2029 so abgelenkt wird, dass er 2037 die Erde trifft.
Das konnte man jahrelang nicht ausschließen. Inzwischen kann man das auch durch
bessere Beobachtungen ausschließen.
Aber der Apophis war jahrelang die Nummer 1 auf unserer Liste.
Da gibt es viele wissenschaftliche Papers dazu.
Deswegen hat er auch einen Namen bekommen, weil er immer wieder diskutiert wurde.
Dann hat man gedacht, jetzt muss man ihm mal einen Namen geben.
Normalerweise zum Beispiel 2012 TC4, das ist einfach 2012, wo der entdeckt T, also A ist 1.
Bis 15. Januar, B ist 16. bis 31.
Januar und das T ist dann irgendwann im Oktober und die werden dann einfach durchnummeriert.
Wir haben jetzt 17.000 in unserer Datenbank, da gehen die Namen irgendwann aus.
So viele Namen hat man einfach nicht. Man weiß ja nicht, wer da jetzt besonders… Also die Meteorologen.
Die haben dafür, für jedes Tief haben die irgendwie einen passenden Namen und
wenn man da nur irgendwelche Vornamen durchcycelt, also bei einer Wortdatenbank
sollte es am Ende nicht scheitern.
Naja gut, jeder so wie er mag.
Ich wollte noch auf die zweite Seite dann hinweisen, das sind die Close Encounters.
Close Approaches.
Close Approaches, ja. Da ist eine Liste, was jetzt so in der nächsten Zeit alles
an der Erde vorbeischramt.
Also kann man gucken im Februar, wer da jetzt als nächstes zu Besuch kommt,
wie weit er vorbeikommt.
Ich glaube, das geht bis zu 7,5 Millionen Kilometer. Das ist das Kriterium,
wenn es weiter vorbei, wenn der Abstand größer ist, dann entscheiden sie nicht
in unserer Liste. wenn sie innerhalb von 7,5 Millionen Kilometer sind,
dann werden sie in dieser Liste aufgeführt.
Und dann sieht man, im März ist der nächste größere Vorbeiflug,
da kommt ein Objekt von 300 paar Meter in einem Abstand von 1,5 Millionen Kilometer
vorbei und der erreicht die Helligkeit von 12, glaube ich.
Und das kann man mit einem guten Teleskop in so einem Garten beobachten.
2017 VR-12, also der ist auch noch nicht so lange auf dem Radar.
Den haben wir am Ende letzten Jahres entdeckt und dann haben wir uns rausgesucht,
wir wollen jetzt mal unsere Radars testen, ob die auch mit dem Radar da gucken können.
Mit dem Radar ist das Problem, da muss man die Energie erst hinschicken und
wenn das eine Million Kilometer weggeschickt wird, nimmt das Signal,
nimmt mit dem Quadrat vom Abstand ab, wird dort reflektiert,
muss wieder zurückwandern, dann
wird es wieder mit dem Quadrat vom Abstand abnehmen, wird es schwächer.
Und also 300 Meter auf eine Million Kilometer Entfernung zu sehen mit einem guten Radar.
Wir haben in Deutschland, in Bonn haben wir eine 34 Meter große Antenne stehen
mit einem guten Radar, mit zwei Megawatt Power da hinten dran.
Da wollen wir mal gucken, ob wir das vielleicht sehen können.
Aber es kann sein, dass es auch trotzdem noch zu klein ist.
Wäre da nicht eine Beobachtung aus dem All viel sinnvoller?
Ja, das wäre toll, wenn wir einen Satelliten im Weltraum hätten,
der aus dem All beobachten könnte. Aber das kostet halt gleich eine Stange.
Das kostet zehnmal mehr Geld. Das ist einfach sehr, sehr teuer.
Die Idee kommt mehr vom Weltraummüll, dass die ihren Müll vom Weltraum aus beobachten.
Das könnten wir uns zusammentun, dass gleichzeitig Asteroiden und Müll beobachtet wird.
Aber wir haben momentan nicht die Finanzierung dafür.
Tja, scheint irgendwie nicht so ein sexy Thema zu sein.
Ja, ich meine, Geld suchen wir erstmal, um unseren Envisat-Satelliten wieder runterzubringen.
Wenn wir jetzt viel Geld zur Verfügung haben, um Weltraum aufzuräumen oder den
Müll zu kontrollieren, zu beobachten, dann wäre es sinnvoll,
unseren Envisat zu entsorgen und da geht schon mal eine halbe Milliarde.
Also der große Erdbeobachtungssatellit, der ja vor ein paar Jahren sich ausgeschaltet
hat und von daher nicht mehr kontrolliert rückgültig war.
Ja, also man bräuchte unendlich viel Geld, um alles abzudecken und vieles zu machen.
Deswegen muss man halt gucken, was man mit dem verfügbaren Geld Sinnvolles machen kann.
Aber ich denke, das Thema Weltraummüll rutscht, glaube ich, am laufenden Meter
nach oben auf der Prioritätenliste, weil es ja einfach potenziell auch irgendwann
mal dazu führen kann, dass man überhaupt gar keine richtige Wachhalt mehr betreiben kann.
Ja, auf jeden Fall, ja.
Vielen Dank.
Wenn wir jetzt sagen, morgen wird hier ein neuer Asteroid entdeckt und der hat
irgendwie so eine Größe von 20, 30 Meter, also schon so einen Bereich von beunruhigend
groß und der geht halt jetzt wirklich mal auf die Erde zu.
Wenn man Glück hat, dann erwischt man den wie viele Monate vorher?
Gut, es gibt zwei Fälle, die 20 Meter, da wird man evakuieren,
den entdeckt man zu spät, dass man noch eine Rakete hinschicken kann.
Also dass wir so weit wären, dass wir Raketen auf Knopfdruck losschicken können,
um die abzufangen oder abzulenken, daran arbeiten wir eigentlich momentan nicht.
Das ist sehr unrealistisch, weil es wird verdammt viel Geld kosten und da ist
eine Evakuierung billiger.
Raketen zur Ablenkung, da reden wir vielleicht von Objekten,
die 100 Meter groß sind und am POFIS zum Beispiel, das war im Gespräch,
dass man den vielleicht ablenken könnte.
Und in Apophis, der wurde, ich weiß nicht, 2002, der war es entdeckt und sollte
2029 die Erde treffen, da hat man 10, 20 Jahre Vorlaufzeit.
Und das ist so ein typisches Szenario, man würde die heute entdecken,
aber der Einschlag wäre in 10 Jahren.
Also Apophis wird das jetzt nicht tun.
Er wird es nicht tun, aber wir werden andere sehen, die erstmal gefährlich sind.
Also wir entdecken ständig neue Asteroiden und am ersten Tag wissen wir nicht,
ob er die Erde trifft oder nicht.
Aber wenn wir ihn ein paar Tage beobachten, meistens stellt sich heraus, er ist keine Gefahr.
Manche landen dann in der Risikoliste, die haben eine kleine Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Aber es wird irgendwann kommen, da werden wir einen Teil sehen und er hat dann
50 Prozent, dass er die Erde trifft.
Und dann müssen wir anfangen, uns Gedanken zu machen. Und da kann ich jetzt
mal erzählen, was wir bei den Vereinten Nationen machen,
weil da wurde 2014 eine Arbeitsgruppe eingerichtet, die heißt Space Mission
Advisory Planning Group.
Die befasst sich dann damit, eine Abwehrmission zu konzipieren,
wo alle Mitgliedstaaten quasi zusammenarbeiten.
Die NASA ist da sehr stark vertreten, wir sind als ESA vertreten,
die Russen haben einen Vertreter dabei.
Jetzt, vor einer Woche, war wieder ein Treffen bei den Vereinten Nationen in Wien.
Die Chinesen haben Antrag gestellt, aufgenommen zu werden.
Die sind jetzt auch in diese Same-Page-Gruppe aufgenommen. und sie haben ein
gutes Statement gemacht,
dass sie auch diese Bedrohung ernst nehmen und dass sie da international kollaborieren
wollen, dass wir da einfach zusammenarbeiten wollen.
Und da gibt es Positionspapiere, wann werden wir aktiv, wie funktioniert es
mit der Informationsverbreitung und da gibt es konkrete Pläne,
was getan werden wird, wenn so eine Situation eintritt.
Und was wird dann getan?
Ja, also der typische Abwehrmechanismus wäre ein kinetischer Einschlag.
Man schickt eine Rakete, jagt eine Rakete gegen den Asteroiden schon ein,
zwei Jahre vor dem Einschlag,
macht eine kleine Bahnänderung durch den Einschlag und wird ihn ja eben von
seiner Bahn geringfügig ablenken und dass er dann ein Jahr später statt die
Erde trifft ganz knapp dran vorbeifliegen würde.
Und riskiert man aber nicht, dass das Ding dann zerbricht und irgendwie ein
noch größeres Problem darstellt?
Das wird alles studiert. Das ist eine Gefahr, dass man es statt das Problem
zu lösen eben noch größer macht, dass wenn dann zehn Teile anfliegen,
dass man dann gar nichts mehr weiß und nichts mehr machen kann.
Man muss den Asteroiden erstmal besser verstehen, ob der leicht auseinanderbricht,
ob das mehr ein Eisenprogn ist oder ob das ein poröse Felsprogn ist,
der leicht auseinanderbricht.
Die Amerikaner, die wollen jetzt ihre Mission DART 2020 zum Asteroiden Didymos starten.
Die wollen da einschlagen und ursprünglich war geplant, dass wir wie der ESA
parallel dazu auch hinfliegen und es beobachten und eben sehen,
ob dieser Einschlag die gewünschte Wirkung erzielt,
ob er kleine Bahnänderungen hervorruft.
Und das sind jetzt Studien, die gemacht werden, also nicht nur Studien,
sondern auch wirkliche Missionen, wo man sowas lernen muss.
Das wird vielleicht nicht gleich beim ersten Mal alles funktionieren,
aber das ist ein Prozess,
dass man halt, wenn es mal so weit ist, dass man das schon ausprobiert hat,
dass man da nicht bei Null anfängt, dass man da schon Raketen hat,
dass man für alles vorbereitet ist, dass man eben weiß,
wie so ein Asterid funktioniert, wie der innen aufgebaut ist und was man alles
vorher lernen muss und untersuchen muss.
Das ist momentan am Kochen und das ist so, was sich bei Asteroidenabwehr momentan bewegt.
Also DART heißt die eine Sonne, das Projekt läuft glaube ich unter AIDA.
Das war AIDA, ist noch mit der ESA zusammen, ist leider gestorben,
ich glaube, Sie wollen es gerade erklären.
Ne, ich weiß nicht, ich wollte nur mal die Begriffe hier klarkriegen,
also sozusagen das Projekt AIDA als solches gibt es so jetzt nicht mehr,
weil das mal anders geplant war, aber diese Sonde DART, die gibt es noch.
AIDA war die Kollaboration zwischen ESA und NASA, bestehend aus DART,
dieses Direct Asteroid Redirection Targeting oder Double Asteroid Redirection Test.
Das ist der Teil, der NASA-Teil, der auch noch besteht, einfach den Einschlag.
Und AIME war der europäische Teil davon, um das zu beobachten.
Die ESA-Mitgliedsstaaten haben das nicht finanziert. Wir haben einen Antrag
gestellt, um das zu finanzieren. Das wurde nicht bewilligt.
Das heißt, die Amerikaner sagen, okay, wir fliegen trotzdem dahin,
wir brauchen euch nicht, wir können das auch unseren Test so machen.
Wir arbeiten jetzt an einer Rescue-Mission, dass wir trotzdem da noch hinfliegen,
allerdings erst zwei Jahre später hinfliegen und in Kader studieren.
Wir wollen verstehen, wie effektiv so ein Einschlag ist, dass wir das dann zwei
Jahre später trotzdem noch untersuchen können und da trotzdem noch Rückschlüsse
ziehen können und was lernen können.
Das ist das momentane Szenario. Also das AI, da gibt es nicht mehr,
aber dieses Dart davon besteht noch.
Aber man weiß ja jetzt eigentlich noch gar nicht, woraus der so besteht.
Ja, das muss man...
Du sagst ja, man müsste ja dann erstmal gucken, Irgendwie ist der porös,
ist der irgendwie fest, Eisenanteil etc.
Aber wenn man es nicht weiß, man haut jetzt trotzdem einfach schon mal drauf.
Also wünschenswert, wenn man genug Zeit hat, wenn man genug Geld hat,
fliegt ja erstmal eine Reconnaissance-Mission hin, eine Aufklärungsmission.
Wir hatten jetzt bei diesem Didymon-Projekt gedacht, dass man da so kleine Cube-Sats noch mitnimmt,
dass man Radiowellen dass der europäische Sonde schickt Radiowellen durch den
Körper durch den Asteroiden durch, auf der anderen Seite wird das Signal empfangen
und durch die Verzerrung von dem Signal auf der anderen Seite kann man Rückschlüsse
vom Inneren von dem Asteroiden schließen,
also wenn man genügend Zeit und Mittel hat kann man vorher, bevor man da einschlägt,
untersuchen wie der aufgebaut ist kostet halt Zeit, kostet zusätzliche Missionen,
wenn man die Zeit nicht hat ähm.
Da muss man wirklich spekulieren und da muss man sich zusammensetzen.
Also da habe ich jetzt kein Patientrezept, wie man da im konkreten Fall vorgehen würde.
Aber wie gesagt, wir sind ja ganz am Anfang, wir sind ja noch am Lernen.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass uns ein 100-Meter-Objekt trifft,
das ist mehr im Zeitraum von 1000 Jahren.
Diese Gefahr ist jetzt nicht so imminent. Und was ich jetzt persönlich meinen
Augenmerk sehe, was ich denke, was ich beitragen kann,
um die Sicherheit zu erhöhen, ist mit diesem Fliegenaugenteleskop diese Objekte
von 20 Metern zu entdecken und Evakuierung aussprechen zu können.
Und das Warnungen auszusprechen.
Die großen Objekte, da muss ich zugeben, da sind wir noch nicht so weit,
dass wir Konzepte auf dem Tisch haben. Wir arbeiten da dran.
Aber wenn das morgen entdeckt werden würde, ich denke, da würde halt alles beschleunigt gehen.
Wenn wir zehn Jahre haben, würde man alles mobilisieren, wie damals bei der
Mondlandung. Dann wäre auch viel mehr Geld zur Verfügung.
Da wäre schon noch viel zu machen. Aber wir haben es noch nicht auf dem Tisch parat.
Aber was würde dann so passieren, wenn man sich jetzt mal so die bisherigen
Strukturen und Erfahrungen anschaut?
Das ist einfach mal so rein hypothetisch. Wir haben also da jetzt mit welchem
Bedrohungsszenario das jetzt anfangen sollte und wo wirklich eine Maßnahme im
All auch geboten wäre. Wo fängt das dann an?
50 Meter, 100 Meter Durchmesser?
Also diese Gruppen, die bei der UN tagen, die haben sich jetzt geeinigt,
wenn die Wahrscheinlichkeit größer ist als ein Prozent und das Objekt ist größer als 20 Meter,
dann wird erstmal das ganze Mechanismus in Gang gesetzt.
Dann fängt man an, das zu beobachten.
Also der Mechanismus überhaupt erstmal gucken, kümmern.
Ja, dann wird es auf die Agenda gesetzt. Okay, das ist jetzt ein Objekt,
das wir ernst nehmen müssen und das wird dann aber erstmal näher studiert.
Weil es hat ja auch nur ein Prozent
Wahrscheinlichkeit und da hat man noch genügend Zeit, da zu reagieren.
Aber dann wird, der nächste Schritt ist dann, was im Englischen Preparedness,
Bereitschaft, quasi Einsatzbereitschaft,
wenn es dann innerhalb von zehn Jahren, wenn die Wahrscheinlichkeit größer ist
als zehn Prozent und dann verlangt man eine Einsatzbereitschaft.
Dann werden quasi alle verfügbaren Institutionen, die da eine Rolle spielen,
in Einsatzbereitschaft versetzt.
Heißt man hält staatsfrei oder man baut schon mal was oder was ist Einsatzbereitschaft?
Ich meine man muss ja auch irgendwas haben, mit dem man dann bereit sein könnte.
Gut, ich glaube, das ist mehr auf dem Boden, dass die Zivilschutzeinrichtungen, das Rote Kreuz und so.
Also bereit auf der Erde quasi, um Maßnahmen zu ergreifen. Ja, ja.
Und gibt es auch schon noch einen anderen definierten Eskalationslevel,
über 10% Wahrscheinlichkeit?
Da gibt es dann wirklich, also was Sie sagen, wann wirklich Raketen und so einsatzbereit
sein sollen, Aber das ist ja momentan ein theoretisches Szenario,
weil die nicht da sind, weil die erst mal alles entwickelt werden müssen.
Aber wie gesagt, wenn morgen jetzt der 50 Meter mit 15 Prozent Einschlagswahrscheinlichkeit
Astrid am Start ist, kann ja sein.
Ja, wir haben da eben Thresholds, wie sagt man im Deutschen,
Schwellen definiert, wann das erreicht ist, dann sollen Raketen bereitgestellt
werden. Aber das nützt uns nichts, weil sie momentan nicht da sind.
Na gut, aber wenn man jetzt zehn Jahre Vorlaufzeit hat?
Ja, also das heißt dann, Hochdruck müssen die gebaut werden und stadtklar gemacht werden.
Da gibt es konkrete Vorstellungen, wann das passieren muss.
Um dann was zu machen?
Um Raketen loszuschicken, um das einzuschlagen und den abzulenken von seiner
Bahn. Das ist momentan das Szenario.
Es gibt viele Möglichkeiten Asteroiden abzulenken, aber das was wir momentan
die Technologie dafür haben, ist einfach mit der Rakete da brutal rein zu rammen
und dann durch einen kleinen Kick ein bisschen abzulenken von der Bahn.
Ich erinnere mich aus anderen Gesprächen noch, dass es irgendwie auch noch so
putzige Ideen gab wie anmalen.
Ja, es gibt, ich habe in meiner Liste glaube ich, acht verschiedene Methoden.
Anmalen war eine Sache, dass quasi die Strahlungsdruck von der Sonne ändert
sich dann, also der hat andere Reflexionskoeffizienten und ändert dann dadurch
auch geringfügig seine Bahn.
Das muss man vielleicht 30 Jahre vorher machen, weil es ja ein ganz,
ganz geringer Effekt, der nur langsam wegbewegt.
Wie so ein Ionentriebwerk, ne?
Ja, aber noch weniger sogar. Es gibt Millionen Triebwerken, dass man da hinfliegt
und dann Millionen beschießt und langsam versucht wegzubringen von seiner Bahn,
dass man eben her mit dem Raumschiff fliegt und durch die Anziehungskraft von
dem Raumschiff wird er leicht von der Bahn wegbewegt.
Es gibt auch ganz extreme Beispiele, dass man Atomsprengköpfe direkt vor ihm
explodieren lässt und dann die Schockwelle ihn ein bisschen ablenkt.
Aber ich glaube, sowas können nur die Amerikaner machen.
In Europa gibt es das so und so nicht. Die Russen könnten sich vielleicht dazu
aufrafen, das mit den Amerikanern anzuschließen.
Ich denke, wenn so wirklich eine Bedrohung käme, Dann würden auf einmal die
Amerikaner, die Russen und die Chinesen, wären die gut Freunde und würden da
doch zusammenarbeiten.
Wenn die Menschheit bedroht wäre, dann denke ich, würden die alle an einem Strang ziehen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man jetzt immer so den Eindruck hat von den USA gerade,
aber auf der wissenschaftlichen Ebene kann ich mir das ganz gut vorstellen.
Das heißt, das sind eigentlich so ein bisschen, das ist so das Besteck,
was jetzt gerade auf dem Tisch liegt.
Also man müsste im Prinzip so eine Situation haben, erkennen und dann sagen,
okay, wir haben jetzt so und so viele Jahre, jetzt geht es darum,
schmeißt man irgendeinen Satelliten von seiner Rakete und dann wird da einfach
was anderes drauf gesetzt, um einfach zu sehen, was können wir da machen.
Aber da müsste ja im Prinzip auch noch das passende Raumfahrzeug dafür entwickelt werden.
Rakete alleine bringt es ja nicht.
Vielleicht können wir die Dragon X nehmen, die wir gestern so schön gesehen
haben, die in so einer tollen Stadt.
Die Falcon Heavy.
Falcon Heavy, ja.
Ja, die kriegt auf jeden Fall schon mal, könnten wir den Asteroiden mit Sportwagen beschießen.
Das ist ja schon mal was.
Ja, also wie gesagt, wir haben momentan nichts zur Verfügung.
In Europa haben wir die Ariane 5, die unsere stärkste Rakete ist.
Da könnten wir einfach nur einen Betonklokts vorne reinsetzen und da drauf jagen.
Die Ariane 6. Das wäre auf jeden Fall schon mal kräftiger.
Und ja, die Japaner haben Raketen, die Inter haben Raketen.
Wenn man da zusammen jeder seine Rakete da reinjagt, müsste natürlich auch ein
bisschen koordiniert werden.
Nicht, dass die einen den nach links verschieben, die anderen schieben wieder zurück nach rechts.
Und am Schluss neutralisiert sich alles. Aber dafür ist eben diese Space Mission
Advisory Group aufgesetzt, dass es koordiniert wird, dass die Leute sich treffen.
Ich meine, in dem Meeting sitzen wir mit den Chinesen, mit den Amerikanern an
einem Tisch und diskutieren das.
Wir sind da noch nicht besonders weit. Die Gruppe gibt es jetzt seit drei Jahren.
Also die konkreten Pläne, was für Raketen da genommen werden und welche Nutzlasten
und wie wir das machen, da sind wir noch am Anfang.
Aber das wird jetzt entwickelt, Konzepte.
Wenn du dir das jetzt mal so rein emotional vorstellst, dass es zu so einem Fall kommt.
Was wäre so deine Erwartung, wie diese weltweite Space-Gemeinde,
die ja auch zum guten Teil in so einem Konkurrenzdruck zueinander steht,
bei aller Zusammenarbeit, wie würde die reagieren?
Wie schnell würde das gehen?
Welche Knoten würden sich da gegebenenfalls lösen, die sonst vorhanden sind?
Also ich hoffe, ich bin da nicht naiv, aber ich denke, das würde wirklich die
Amerikaner und Russen zwingen,
zusammen zu kooperieren und sie müssen ja nicht eine Rakete zusammenbauen,
aber es wäre schon gut, wenn die amerikanischen Russen die selber,
also jeder seine eigene Rakete gleichzeitig zum selben Punkt einschlagen lässt,
dass es einfach verdoppelt, dass sie,
ja, dass jeder seine Mission macht,
aber dass sie genau das gleiche Ziel verfolgen und da sehe ich keine,
Schwierigkeiten, warum das nicht möglich sein sollte.
Ich meine, Wenn eine große Bedrohung folgt, was das ganze Weltklima beeinflussen
würde, wo Amerikaner genauso wie Russen, wie Chinesen, Europäer gleichzeitig betroffen wird.
Wir werden alle von der Klimakatastrophe gleichzeitig bedroht.
Da kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass die Kooperation besser funktionieren würde.
Auf wissenschaftlichem Gebiet ist es so und so. Also wenn wir auf Konferenzen
gehen, wir tauschen uns mit Amerikanern, mit Russen, mit allen aus.
Das ist eigentlich sehr freundschaftlich und man wundert sich manchmal,
warum die ganze Welt so kriegerisch und so ist, wenn eigentlich auf unserer
Ebene, wo wir Wissenschaftler sind, das sind alles vernünftige Leute und die
haben friedliche Ziele im Zweck, im Blick.
Und ja, wir wollen ja, alle wollen ja die Asteroiden abwehren.
Ich denke, da kann man schon, sollte man eine Lösung finden,
aber vielleicht bin ich auch zu naiv und die Menschheit schafft es doch irgendwie sich auszurotten.
Die EU hat ja auch so ein Projekt gestartet, das NeoShield. Was steckt da dahinter?
Da wurde auch konkret untersucht, wie man Asteroiden ablenken kann.
Da hat Airbus in Friedrichshafen diesen Vertrag gewonnen.
Die haben dann studiert, alle verschiedenen Möglichkeiten, wie man einen Asteroiden ablenkt.
Ich war in einer Präsentation, da habe ich gesehen, wie sie diesen Gravity Tractor vorgestellt haben.
Das Raumschiff fliegt neben dem Asteroiden her.
Das ist schon zehn Jahre vorher die Erde treffen würde, weil die Kraft,
die ein Raumschiff auf den Asteroiden auswirkt, ist sehr gering.
Das Problem ist nur, wenn er angezogen wird und den Asteroiden wegzieht,
dann irgendwann würde er auf den Asteroiden drauffallen.
Das heißt, er muss seine Steuerdüsen als Gegenkraft wirken, damit er immer im
gleichen Abstand von dem Asteroiden bleibt.
Und diese Düsen, die dürfen auch nicht den Asteroiden treffen,
weil dann wird er ja statt angezogen, wird er wieder abgelenkt.
Das heißt, das ist nicht so ein einfaches Konzept, aber die haben sich Gedanken
gemacht, wie man das lösen kann, in welchem Abstand man da fliegen muss,
wie lange man da nebenher fliegen muss und wir haben da interessante Studien gemacht.
Und haben natürlich auch den Kinesischen Impact untersucht und haben quasi so
eine Landkarte gemacht, wenn der Asteroid so und so groß ist,
wenn er in so und so vielen Jahren die Erde trifft,
welches Projekt, welches Konzept ist am vielversprechendsten,
haben Kostenschätzungen gemacht, was so Missionen kosten und haben das eigentlich
ganz gut untersucht, was man für Asteroidenablenkung braucht und wie man das umsetzen kann.
Das war also eine komplette Feasibility-Studie, Machbarkeitsstudie.
Gibt es denn sonst noch irgendwelche Gefahren, die uns drohen? Außer Asteroiden?
Außer Asteroiden, ja, auf der Erde gibt es genügend.
Und Präsidenten. Nee, ich meine jetzt so mal konkret, braut sich noch irgendwas anderes zusammen?
Also ich meine, die Müllproblematik haben wir ja im Prinzip schon angesprochen.
Es gab ja auch immer mal wieder härtere Kollisionen.
Also gibt es irgendwelche Also Vorfälle, die man sich jetzt nicht gerade herbei
wünscht, aber die durchaus passieren könnten,
eben zum Beispiel Kollisionen von Raumfahrzeugen, die sich in irgendeiner Form
besonders negativ nicht nur für diese Raumfahrzeuge auswirken könnten,
so als Umweltbelastung oder so?
Ja gut, also der Weltraummüll, was die Chinesen 2007 gemacht haben,
dass sie ihren Satelliten selber abgeschossen haben, nur um der Welt zu demonstrieren,
dass sie es können, dass sie gleichberechtigte Partner mit den Amerikanern sind. Wir können das auch.
Und dass wir jetzt jede Woche Warnungen bekommen, da kommt wieder ein chinesisches
Müllteil angeflogen, macht da mal ein Ausweichmanöver.
Also jede Woche haben wir da Ärger damit, mit diesen Teilen.
Das ist eine Riesenkatastrophe und zwei Jahre später sind dann das Iridium mit
dem Kosmos-Satelliten zusammengestoßen und haben in diesen 800 Kilometern nochmal
2500 Trümerteile hinzugefügt.
Das sind massive Probleme für unsere Operations, die wir hier betreiben.
Wir fliegen unsere Satelliten in diesen Bahnen, weil man von dort aus wunderbar
die Erde abscannen kann.
Wir machen Erdbeobachtung mit unseren Satelliten. Wir wollen ja das Klima besser verstehen.
Wir wollen unsere Eiskappen vermessen im Nord- und Südpol.
Und wir müssen in diese Bahnen fliegen, weil man von dort aus eben das am besten beobachten kann.
Und das ist jetzt so zugemüllt, dass wir ständig damit ausweichen müssen und
das wird ja nicht besser, das wird ja von Jahr zu Jahr schlimmer und also für
die Raumfahrt sehe ich das als großes Problem.
Die Asteroiden, die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist viel geringer, die Intervalle sind
viel größer, wann uns was treffen wird.
Aber gut, wir müssen die Technologie entwickeln und wenn was passieren würde,
dann wird jeder fragen, warum habt ihr uns nicht gewarnt, warum habt ihr nichts
dagegen getan, auch wenn die Wahrscheinlichkeit gering ist.
Da muss man sich darauf vorbereiten. Und wenn ich mal das Budget anspreche,
wir haben jetzt für diese dritte Phase, es sind vier Jahre, bei 25 Millionen Euro.
Da geht ein Großteil in unser FlyEye-Fliegenauge-Teleskop hinein.
Ich denke, das ist eine gerechtfertigte Ausgabe, um sich vorzubereiten für einen Asteroideneinschlag.
Und dann den Müll zum Beispiel, diesen Envisar zu entsorgen,
da sprechen wir von 500 Millionen Euro. Das ist eine ganz andere Hausmarke.
Und da müssen sich die Mitgliedstaaten oder muss vielleicht der Bürger Druck
machen, was ist mir wichtiger,
habe ich mehr Angst vor Asteroiden oder ist es ethisch unverantwortlich,
dass wir den Weltraum zumüllen und müssen wir da anfangen aufzuräumen.
Ist das denn, also erstmal noch gefragt, wie viel Prozent schlimmer muss es
eigentlich noch werden mit dem Müll, bis wir so ein richtiges Problem haben?
Sind wir da so am Anfang, ist da irgendwie schon 5 vor 12, wie muss man sich das so vorstellen?
Gegenfrage, Kohlendioxid, wie viel muss CO2 noch ansteigen, bevor wir was tun müssen?
Ja, da müssen wir jetzt schon was tun.
Plastikmüll in den Meeren ist auch.
Schon high time.
Genauso ist es im Weltraum. Das ist seit Jahren predigen wir,
das muss was getan werden.
Es gibt Konferenzen, es gibt Beschlüsse. Ich war jetzt bei den Vereinten Nationen,
die Ägypter sagen, ihr müsst was da oben tun.
Jeder sagt, ihr müsst was tun. Aber die Politiker, die denken vier Jahre im
Voraus. In den nächsten vier Jahren wird da oben im Weltraum nicht viel passieren.
Da wird keine Space Station zerschossen werden.
Wir werden wahrscheinlich unsere Erdbeobachtungssatelliten nicht verlieren.
Vier Jahre passiert nichts, also lassen wir doch das der nächsten Generation
übrig, um da aufzuräumen. Das ist traurig, aber so funktioniert die Menschheit.
Deswegen vorhin nochmal die PR-Gag in Tscheljabinsk.
Es muss immer erst was passieren, dann wird großer Hype gemacht,
dann wird auch mal wieder kurzfristig Geld reingesteckt und dann wird es wieder
vergessen und es passiert einfach viel zu wenig,
weil die Politiker nur über ihre Legislaturperiode hinaus, also für vier Jahre
hinausdenken und nicht weiter.
Das müsste irgendein Meteor mal die Villen im Tessin treffen.
Vielleicht sollte man die Abwehraktion von Asteroiden besser steuern und da
mal ein bisschen eingreifen.
Okay, also das Problem ist heute schon sehr groß. Man muss eigentlich gegensteuern.
Das ist ja im Prinzip auch ein Sinneswandel in der ganzen Art und Weise,
wie Missionen eigentlich ausgerichtet werden sollten.
Also alles hat so seinen Sinn und man braucht Telekommunikationssatelliten und
man will natürlich Erdbeobachtung machen und Deep Space Missionen machen,
aber im Prinzip müsste diese ganze Müllproblematik einen extrem großen Stellenwert
bekommen, wenn ich die richtig verstehe.
Also bei der ESA haben wir schon quasi interne Gesetze verfasst,
die gültig sind, dass wir unsere Satelliten nicht ewig oben lassen können.
Es gibt diese 25 Jahre Regel, dass Satelliten nach 25 Jahren verglühen müssen
oder zurückgebracht werden müssen.
Das ist bei uns gefordert. Also wir können dagegen nicht verstoßen.
Wenn wir ein neues Projekt vorschlagen, dann müssen wir genügend Treibstoff
mitnehmen, dass am Ende der Mission eben weiter runtergebracht wird.
Die NASA, auch die Japaner, die Russen, die haben ähnliche Vorschriften.
Die Vorschriften sind eigentlich da, es sollte eigentlich besser werden.
Aber es gibt immer wieder Explosionen im Weltraum. Auch letztes Jahr waren da
wieder einige Satelliten, die einfach explodiert sind.
Ist es Schlampigkeit, ist es Pech, warum das immer wieder passiert,
es ist mir schleierhaft, warum da kein Fortschritt erzielt wird,
es gibt viele Gesetze, die gemacht wurden, die eingehalten werden,
die das Problem aber trotzdem nicht lösen und das ist ein bisschen frustrierend,
also ich denke die ESA, die hat das gemacht, was sie kann, wir erzeugen keinen
neuen Müll mehr, aber dann ist halt wie gesagt Envisat, der geht uns verloren,
da kann man sich nicht dagegen versichern man könnte halt jetzt anfangen dahin
Verfliegenden wieder einzusammeln und ja da fehlt dann doch wieder die Bereitschaften
und der Wille da richtig was zu tun aber ja es wird schon viel getan aber es ist doch noch zu wenig.
Es gibt aus den 80ern diesen wunderschönen, also wunderschön ist gut gesagt,
den Science-Fiction-Film Quiet Earth.
Den fand ich ganz bemerkenswert, weil er so mit dieser Idee spielt,
was ist, wenn alle unsere Infrastruktur auf einmal aufhört zu funktionieren.
Keine Menschen mehr da, alles läuft einfach nur so genauso weiter,
wie es jetzt gerade so ist.
Was wäre, wenn wir jetzt alles abschalten, was hier so an Raumfahrtkontrollzentren
existiert und all das, was sozusagen gerade um die Erde herumfliegt,
würde einfach sich komplett selbst überlassen?
Ja, ich würde erst mal sagen, da muss jeder mit dem Auto ohne sein Navi irgendwo wieder ankommen.
Und das wird schon viele Leute vor großem Problem stecken.
Ich wollte jetzt nicht meinen, was wir so an Komfortverlust erleiden,
sondern was würde mit dem ganzen Gerät da oben passieren, wenn man es nicht
mehr kontrolliert oder kann?
Das kommt auf die Höhe. Wir sind von der Atmosphäre umgeben und bei 600 Kilometer
Höhe fliegen die Teile vielleicht noch so 10, 20 Jahre herum,
aber die verglühen langsam, weil da die Atmosphäre noch relativ stark ist und
die werden abgebremst und die verglühen.
Bei 800 Kilometer sind es dann schon mal 500 bis 1000 Jahre.
Das heißt, der Müll da oben, der wird noch 500 Jahre weiter da rumkreisen.
Und wenn wir mal in einen geostationären Ring gehen, wo unsere Fernsehsatelliten sind,
die bleiben da ewig, da ist keine Atmosphäre mehr, die verschwinden da nicht,
die würden vielleicht ihre Bahn leicht ändern, die würden hin und her geistern,
aber wir haben die schon über eine Million Jahre gerechnet und die fliegen da
immer noch in der Gegend herum.
Also wo unsere Raumstation herumfliegt, 400 Kilometer Höhe, da wird schön aufgeräumt.
Die Atmosphäre würde schön säubern, aber so über 800, über 1000 Kilometer,
das wird Jahrhunderte, wird der Müll weiter sich da herumtreiben und die Teile
würden zusammenstoßen.
Irgendwann kriegt man dann so einen Ring wie Saturn, da haben wir unseren richtigen
Müllring, der da herumkreist.
Selbst wenn wir gar nichts machen, also irgendwann kollidieren die Teile und
werden zerbröselt in kleinere Teile und dann haben wir so einen Staubring drumherum.
Sieht dann irgendwie ganz neu aus sozusagen die Erde aus dem Weltall in ein paar hundert Jahren.
Ja, es gibt schöne Cartoons, da fliegt so ein Außerirdischer an der Erde vorbei
und sieht den Müllregen und sagen, ach guck, da gibt es auch,
das muss wohl bewohnt gewesen sein, da gibt es ja ganz viel Müll drumherum.
Ui, irgendwie auch frustrierend. Ja, Rudiger, haben wir noch irgendwas Wichtiges unerwähnt gelassen?
Ja, ich mache Werbung für den 30. Juni, da feiern wir unseren Asteroid Day,
der wird jetzt von den Vereinten Nationen, ist der auserkoren, weil im Jahre 1908 am 30.
Juni ist in Tunguska in Sibirien ein 50 Meter Asteroid explodiert,
hat da eine Fläche von 2000 Quadratkilometern, so groß wie Groß London,
platt gemacht, hat den ganzen Wald platt gemacht.
Das sogenannte Tunguska-Ereignis.
Und da haben wir in Darmstadt wieder ein Event.
Wir haben die Details noch nicht geklärt, aber das ist immer so eine Möglichkeit,
die Öffentlichkeit zu informieren.
Da laden wir auch Pressevertreter ein und erzählen dann, wie groß ist das Risiko, was wird getan.
Dann stellen wir auch unser Fliegenauge-Teleskop wieder vor,
was das Fortschritte gemacht hat, wie weit wir mit Beobachtung sind und versuchen
einfach die Öffentlichkeit zu informieren und über das Thema aufzuklären.
Und da kann man dann auch irgendwie sich beteiligen?
Wir haben normalerweise letztes Jahr eine kleine Anzahl von,
weil wir nicht so viel Platz haben, an Plätzen vergeben.
Wir müssen die Details noch ausarbeiten. Eine Option war das auch mit der TU
Darmstadt zusammen zu organisieren, dann wäre das ein öffentlicher Vortrag an der TU.
Das wird auch live gestreamt, also jeder kann es per Livestream dann auch zu
Hause vom Laptop verfolgen aber wie gesagt,
die Details werden noch ausgearbeitet, aber wenn man Asteroid Day googelt ein
paar Tage vorher oder Wochen vorher dann findet man alle Informationen dazu
AsteroidDay.org Genau,
da gibt es eine Webseite dazu Ja.
Dann sage ich vielen Dank für die Ausführungen hier zum Müll- und Asteroidenproblem
was wir teilweise schon haben und teilweise Gott sei Dank noch nicht haben.
Aber kann ja sein, dass mal was passiert und es ist sicherlich ganz sinnvoll,
da schon mal vorher drüber nachgedacht zu haben, dass man da nicht gleich auf
dem linken Fuß erwischt wird.
Wir tun unser Bestes.
Ja, das merke ich. Dann noch viel Glück und Erfolg hier beim SSA und allen anderen
Missionen. Vielen Dank.
Dankeschön.
Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Hier bei Raumzeit geht bald weiter.
Bis bald. Tschüss. Bis bald.